[Música]
ella estaba bailando casi me pilla
bailando al aire estamos ahora en la
sección de salud con más romeros a la
mar bienvenida feliz el viernes feliz
fin de semana bueno ya casi el fin de
semana vamos a hablar entonces de esta
semana de concientización sobre el uso
de los antibióticos un problema que nos
debe preocupar más porque lamento
quitarte de tu escenario de fin de
semana y de baile porque en verdad la
verdad es que el problema si es grave
raúl entonces él logra manos de ellos
pongámonos pongámonos serios es un
problema grave que está empezando a
crecer y que además nos está acechando
ya desde hace unos años lo que pasa es
que después de años de usar antibióticos
las bacterias han desarrollado
resistencia y por lo tanto no nos
responden ante estos medicamentos es un
proceso relativamente natural no que
responde también a las lógicas de la
evolución pero que se está agravando en
los últimos años ahora detallaremos
porque básicamente lo que ocurre es que
hay infecciones que no se pueden tratar
y esto ya está provocando varias muertes
en hoy en día se calcula que en 2020 700
mil personas murieron por esto por causa
de esta resistencia de las bacterias a
los antibióticos y que sí no en 2050
serán 10 millones de personas las que
pueden fallecer por esto para hacernos
una idea actualmente 8,2 millones de
personas mueren por cáncer cada año
entonces podría llegar a ser un problema
de salud pública de las mismas
dimensiones mar y también importante no
automedicarse porque así también no
crear resistencia a estos antibióticos
pero ahora le pregunto qué consecuencias
tiene que las bacterias desarrollen esta
resistencia a los antibióticos es como
muy bien decías lo principal es que hay
infecciones que no se pueden tratar y
uno de los problemas precisamente es el
consumo poco responsable ahora
hablaremos de eso por un lado hay
enfermedades bacterianas que ya no se
están pudiendo tratar ha pasado con la
neumonía ha pasado con la tuberculosis
han visto casos de pacientes cuyas
bacterias son tan resistentes que no han
podido obtener un tratamiento con los
antibióticos por otro lado sucede que
los médicos pueden demorarse mucho en
encontrar un antibiótico que sí funcione
contra una infección y en ese tiempo
pues la enfermedad obviamente se agrava
y por último esto este problema también
puede tener consecuencias sobre muchas
áreas de la medicina y también de la
cirugía eso se lo preguntamos al doctor
josé luís martínez es microbio ligó y
microbiólogo perdón del csic de
investigaciones públicas de españolas y
esto fue lo que nos contó si tenemos
sistemas mejores para luchar contra la
infección qué duda cabe que el problema
sanitario será menor y dentro de eso
quiero destacar las vacunas las vacunas
contra las bacterias patógenas suelen
ser peores que contra los virus hay por
ser vacunas pero habría que progresar en
la vacunación para utilizar bien los
antibióticos desarrollar sistemas de
diagnóstico que nos puedan decir si una
bacteria resistente o no en un par de
horas hay que romper las rutas por las
cuales las bacterias se transmiten y
dentro de eso dentro del concepto de
salud única son importantes los
contactos de humanos con animales y
también a través de las aguas residuales
controlar adecuadamente el buen
tratamiento de las aguas residuales es
esencial también para luchar contra la
resistencia a los antibióticos bueno
aquí el doctor ha apuntado algunas de
las soluciones a este problema pero
precisamente quedándonos todavía un poco
en los problemas una de las cosas que
hablaban es que no se puede hacer
cirugías por ejemplo los trasplantes
podrían quedar comprometidos por culpa
de las infecciones escuchemos lo que nos
comentaba
el problema de las infecciones es que si
no tenemos sistemas para evitar y tratar
las infecciones hay muchos
procedimientos médicos que no los
podemos realizar por ejemplo de un
trasplante un trasplante el paciente
queda inmunosuprimido una vez que está
inmunosuprimido es propenso a tener una
infección
si tú no tienes un sistema para prevenir
esa infección estaremos comprometidos
con nuestras plantas estaremos
comprometidos con las grandes cirugías
estaremos comprometidos con las prótesis
con la cátedra y con la cateterización
porque porque son procedimientos que
llevan a la infección y sobre todo en
los pacientes hospitalizados que son
pacientes que están debilitados mari le
pregunto por qué surge este problema
ahora pues es una gran pregunta porque
la verdad es que ese problema ha
sucedido siempre no que las bacterias
han ido desarrollando
resistencia de los antibióticos pasó con
la penicilina en los años 60 por ejemplo
pero en los últimos tiempos una de las
cosas que lo acelerado precisamente es
ese consumo irresponsable de
antibióticos y un gran ejemplo es lo que
ha ocurrido con la pandemia de kobe 19 y
es que al inicio de la pandemia cuando
todavía no se sabía muy bien qué hacer
muchas veces se administraba a los
pacientes con kobe grave
para combatir una infección que en
verdad está provocada por un virus los
antibióticos sirven para combatir las
bacterias no los virus eso pasó hasta el
94 por ciento de los casos de coín grave
en la región americana según cifras de
la organización panamericana de la salud
y en verdad sólo era útil para el 8% de
los casos que si desarrollaban
infecciones secundarias por culpa de
esta enfermedad eso revela un uso
totalmente desproporcionado que hace
pensar a muchos expertos que la pandemia
de hecho ha acelerado esta resistencia a
los antibióticos rápidamente marc
posibilidad de fabricar antibióticos
nuevos entonces pues la verdad siempre
hay esas posibilidades pero actualmente
lo que pasa es que hay un vacío hay un
vacío científico pero sobre todo lo que
hay es un vacío en el mercado de los
antibióticos lo que pasa es que
fabricarlos no es rentable para las
farmacéuticas porque es un tratamiento
barato que dura pocos días y que además
efectivamente cura algo que debería ser
una buena noticia pero que en este caso
juega en contra lo podemos comparar por
ejemplo con el mercado oncológico el
mercado del cáncer la investigación
privada la inversión privada perdón en
investigación oncológica puede llegar a
los 9 mil 700 millones de dólares
mientras que la investigación en los
antibióticos actualmente 132 millones de
dólares las ganancias que generan los
fármacos contra el cáncer también son
millonarias del mercado de los
antibióticos en cambio genera pérdidas
eso hace que sólo haya 43 antibióticos
en los ensayos clínicos actualmente nos
vamos a quedar sin antibióticos para
tratar estas infecciones si dejamos todo
en las manos privadas por favor no nos
vamos a automedicar más grave problemas
mar muchísimas gracias feliz fin de
semana voy con mi segundo invitado el
día